- I need to get out of the street go
away
well better it hits me that hits you
that's true back that up I didn't even
come off the throttle dude that was full
throttle Wow I gotta go back and watch
that I was exciting welcome everybody's
actually pumpkins live not live anymore
shot live and then pre-recorded welcome
today's three-part got sick
oh yeah we're sick is hack but today's
episode is sponsored by Brook linen Noom
quip and honey
today's episode is co-hosted by ela
Klein the beautiful and sick and also
co-hosted by ethan klein that's me sick
huh well we're both hope we're both
co-hosts right or my the host I always
feel like you're the host and I'm just
here your host Ethan and ela who's just
here I hope you guys enjoyed my scooter
riding we have spotted a new scooter
that I'd like to pitch to you all tell
me what you think
this one is $7,000 and I do think that I
do think there's a good chance I'm gonna
buy this if I'm being totally honest
with you huh it's like an off-road camo
military-grade scooter did you oh you
probably muted the stone look at this
off-roading
he's hitting dirt amazing he's got like
tank grids 32 Molitor 32 km/h it goes
snow engineered to scale up terrain with
a 60% what is this for
Oh he'd this is a van bro
can you imagine that Rob some dude who's
like disabled cruising around in this
thing
it would be good to carry all the
groceries back so it's seven thousand
bucks and I think that one would
literally crush the gas but you could
roll over the gas fee on that thing I
don't know for seven thousand bucks it
seems goodbye
now last time it was 3,500 and we were
like should we buy it should we not and
then it was definitely the best well
spent
it's not already got my money okay thing
is I'm not sure that thing we need to go
off-roading
you can't utilize that in the office but
I'm thinking if I make a video with the
Gatsby and then I come in over the top
at the end with like the pretty boy what
do you call that wheelchair a tank
there's got to be a funnier name than
that it's like the leave it at that but
I'm I'm super excited I've got a new toy
to motivate me and it's a hybrid - they
call it tank electric wheelchair hi
Britain who's I think it takes a diesel
diesel operate that day I think it was
just a hybrid like it's it's half tank
half wheelchair half army of massive
weapon of mass destruction F completely
disabled half over white half dick
weapon of mass destruction that
describes me dunno if you go down to
Venice Beach and that thing people
[ __ ] trip and you can go in the sand
yeah charge people who are relaxing on
the sand can you imagine now that's a
prank video I'd like to see I'm happy to
announce that we also have new scooter
videos for all of our enjoyment as we
know the scooter people are close and
dear to our hearts they're a menace to
society they're a danger to our children
yada yada yada this one's great this one
I like because as I'll play for you now
I'm in Munich cuz I don't know what kind
of Riverdance [ __ ] they're listening
to but the kids are River dancing now
you'll notice Graham in the back corner
there she goes she's moving and she just
takes out girl
now what's so great if I can go back for
a moment is that the girl is so on faith
I mean her arms don't even come on
profit as great as Nana pushes her out
of frame so watch this
Nana's like oh I'm going in there
watching this show see someone pays by
Nana and they come back I love that
dance it's a river dance you never seen
that there was a girl might like middle
school is all about river dancing Nana
slowly goes back to man good thing Nana
didn't have a gas-filled I said girl be
dead sure did that kids can't knit
though let's talk about this kid who's
getting it he's still screwing around in
the back doing the show this dude's
giving it his all and Nana stole the
damn show that girl never came back
though that girl she took out just fell
everybody's watching the show and then
I'm so rude maybe just watch the show
what is the context of this situation
there's a bunch of old people watching
something is doing a Riverdance and I
don't even think most of them are
looking you know why are all the
balloons green the st. Patrick's Day at
a return Oh daddy's got all this what do
you uh
Sherlock Holmes over here okay if you're
such a genius weapon and the girl that
you scooted off frame when she dead
she's gone honestly and so Jay takes me
a minute to understand and so I just
want to watch this one more time before
we move on so I think it's already
happening the tragedy so here's Nana
here's the girl in chair as fate would
have it they're a goofy are kind of
dance than this no I don't think so your
cousin Anna I loved kamikazes into her
till like man is just scooting you out
of there so there you have it wheelchair
people are out of control
now if all people shouldn't be allowed
to drive cars should they be allowed to
drive nobility late or not there you go
they should just be confined to their
own space
he shouldn't be a lot of public
according to healing order here well
it's a lot aegis wuo but okay we got
another scooter video I don't know
what's with scooter people they're
trying to hit these this is the second
good a person I've seen trying to hit a
halfpipe at a skate park you know and it
doesn't work out for them for her either
it's not much of an incline I love how
just all their scooter gear falls out
although the sound of coins fine because
these scooter people have like their
whole life in that scooter did you hear
all those coins
yeah bunch of loose change let's try to
see what actually falls out you couldn't
even hit like a 5% incline like it's
just a bunch of receipts loose change
gee I don't know she's got a lot of
stuff what are you doing in the skate
park man it's pretty incredible well
makes me want to take the gas we don't
know skatepark Columbia no that's true
but I'm just gonna eat [ __ ] like all
these people do different well you got
the gaps be a little better equipped
that's true and I'm more skilled driver
you saw me back up younger now this one
was fit I just a little a little younger
a little more this this one blew me away
I can't believe what I'm watching here
fun being on it these two dudes at the
beach each on a mobility scooter they're
going to war they are straight-up like
an old school chariot war
oh there's one behind the other and now
they're gonna ram into each other this
guy's we're all speed I think you're
laughing in the back so I can't tell if
they're if there's I can't help there
yeah the bigger is if they're if this is
hostile or not but so that one's on the
phone now and then the other guy I think
he's laughing but he just rammed his
and I mean these guys are out of their
minds if they're kidding around well
they were out of their minds either way
but now that guy a brother this is like
chariot chariot wars of old we got to
get these two gladiators in us this is
the best exactly look at these two guys
go they're like 5 inches dude Wow do you
think it's anger or joy that they're
doing this I think it's a joy because
these things as we saw are not that
cheap the scooters wonder what happened
to cause and who told us it's kind of
like a status quo you gotta show off you
owe your status symbol you gotta show
off your new scoot and you don't want to
have any damage going on that oh you
know he's probably calling 9-1-1 I don't
think it's a friendly cuz I thought I
saw this guy laughing but it's hard to
tell but they may come on what kind of
what kind of caused such a rift between
these uh distinguished gentlemen well I
was blocking the way you know and it's
kind of like when you see people
fighting over a parking spot hmm this is
the mobility mobility fights that you
will see I think they probably both came
from a deli and one of them got the last
bowl of soup or something yeah exactly
this is so this is so poignant like of
all the scooter videos we've watched I
would have never dreamed that I'd find
two old men playing chicken and well
look at the dinner they get good they
hit admit they go you're gone you can
tell they're both kind of heavy air
they're still flying
so they both Florida and went head-on
and and just slammed into each other and
they jumped out of their seats like for
good 5 inches there
I think this might be my favorite the
video but then I was like wow it's right
on cue
so scooter people are still brazii yeah
I'm happy to announce and meanwhile Gila
if we do everyone go off-roading in our
Gatsby I loved is covered with a with
this two minutes I don't know it was a
fan submissions email I love so we're
good I looked at it's got three reviews
on Amazon I think you may want to read
one of them mmm with pleasure
three ratings it's got four and a half
stars pretty good me and my best friend
Gary used to go LARPing and a pro we'd
always arrived dripping wet but when we
came across his amazing invention
let's just say it now keeps us from
drowning and other things wink wink I
don't know what it means exactly
astounding me and my life partner
searching your state comfortably drying
our ventures through Africa oh maybe for
a motorcycle dude can you imagine
running down do people in Africa a trip
if they saw that talk about white devil
did I love them me and my best friend
Gary but that's a good not keep us from
drowning and other things wink wink wink
wink I think that's all people comment
our ping do not LARPing is no it's like
real-life role-playing oh when you
pretend you're like a wizard and live
action yeah okay yeah that's a goof
about an email Lauren thank you for this
Thank You percent here's the most legit
review I like it
okay look at all their related product
what the file kinds of styles of ponchos
shit's crazy adult waterproof rain
poncho bites
call rain creeps alright let's get out
of this like that so it's good to people
are still brazii I'm happy to say and
I'm still open submissions we can't get
enough scooter people I've become one of
them in other news three beats slide DMC
aid removed and gave us a strike of all
the people to go to war with did you
ever expect to be three beats like a
family what was the song they did they
go boogie Oh something about love it was
the bomb yeah love bomb yeah something
it was that with the strange dad and his
strange two kids in Hawaii who make
music together they they removed our
podcast I said yo you really want to do
this I you know I'm like listen I fought
fair use' in court and won and I write
the case and everything I was like you
guys really want to do this they're like
yeah we do want to do this and there's
another company in front of them like
vid I don't know one of these stupid
companies just claims people for people
for claims videos for people but they
did they took it down so I'm disputing
it now and I invite them to sue me I
would love I actually would I think this
is a great case because I'll tell you
what happened you've got a two hour long
podcast we watched the last two minutes
of the podcast we were commenting on
their new song celebrating its release
and then so first they claimed the whole
two-hour episode of the podcast for a
two minute clip at the end yeah now
that's never been fought in Kate there's
never gonna press it in about about this
issue of copyright where you can claim a
two hour long video because somebody use
30 seconds of your work something like
that so I think that would be a really
important precedent to just to explore
in court and second you know thirdly
finally secondly something Lee see I'm
all thank you see
what do you mean see like ABC Sealy that
I'm always happy I'm more equipped I'm
more knowledgeable have more resources
than I ever did to fight this in court
so three Beach slide if you want to come
at me if you want to sue me baby I'm all
game ready three beats slide doesn't
sound like them right I wonder if it's
just that company but they are not aware
I wonder who's liable because the
company is the one that issued the DMCA
mm-hm and and Dan you had a
communication with them as well right
well just a very generic stock response
that they gave when they declined our
appeal let me show you guys in case
anyone's confused about who we're
talking about its these uh this genius
here I don't know I can see this guy I
could it's hard to I don't know who's
doing it but ultimately I would assume
it's damn who were who is liable but who
knows but I I countered it the video
will be back up and I I would make my
day dude I am ready to continue to
defend fair use in court I'm better I'm
more educated I got more resources I'm
ready dude Matt Haas got me at the worst
time ever we were broke we we were
unsure because there was never a
precedent like that set before but we
were up for the fight this time I'm
salivating I'm I invite you please come
at me let's do this do it I've already
won once you think I can't do it again
let's go dude look at the you can't
handle getting goofed on a little bit
you gotta earn you don't know I'm giving
them the benefit of the doubt because
they've always been this company go out
of the way they've always been like the
goofy kind that everyone like I wouldn't
go out of the way though why would this
company go out of the way cuz that's
what this is what happened with prank
invasion back in the day is that
collective whatever it's called that
really terrible Network why is any oh
wait for square
maybe it was no yeah it was full screen
actually you're right and full screen
was the one that took down our video and
so I was like Chris what's up why are
you taking down our shed and Chris is
like Oh full screen they did it but like
come on I did full screen wouldn't
create a liability for themselves unless
thought hardest ask them to but I was
thinking oh this is the only chance
they're gonna get to make money is to
claim our podcasts because our podcast
gets a million views it's two hours long
so it generates a nice bit of revenue
couple thousand bucks and their video is
never gonna make that much so they're
gonna claim our entire podcast because
we goofed on them for two minutes at the
end of the podcast it's obscene I'm
still a believer and their wholesome
family and I think they're just having
fun and I don't know well whatever
whoever um um I don't care I mean
everybody's got a burr no I'm just
saying I don't know if I would point the
finger at and then I have a hard time
thinking that he wasn't aware of it okay
but I could I mean I could be wrong I
mean I'm just assuming I have no way to
know yeah but the reason I think that is
because originally Dan you have the
correspondents they said they said
something about forwarding it to the
artist no I hear I have the message
right here they didn't say anything
about the artist yeah I mean it their
message seems to be indicating they're
just doing it on behalf of them so thank
ya well thank you for contacting
providing us URL Vidia is the company
spell it v y dia is playing in this
segment on behalf of the copyright
holder please note if you accept the
claim the segment using the copyrighted
material takedown is not necessary after
review our rights management team are
enforcing the claim so this is this was
after appeal that they said and I was
like oh on it I was like okay dude put
me in touch with your lawyers they
respond which they never responded with
yeah I think you should probably ask
your manager cuz I know what I'm talking
about
they're like all free money Oh free
money I claim video and get free money
on YouTube I Duke weird kind of luck I
may not love but it's amazing that in
the years of doing this podcast it's the
[ __ ] three beats strike ever I'm
telling you I haven't gotten a strike in
years yeah I have a hole I have a whole
rant about this okay well first of all
when it comes to the type of person Matt
Haas was not the person I expected to
sue me and go to court over to the thing
is that the big license holders like you
know the Viacom's and Sony's or whatever
they know that it's not worth the effort
and they know because they actually have
lawyers they know that it's not worth
and they have a losing case still on top
of it so they are literally just
exploiting the vulnerabilities in the
DMCA system now these guys actually
don't know what they're doing they
individual the individuals and they're
the ones that will take it all the way
because they don't understand myself I
don't have good counsel and they don't
really know what they're getting
themselves in so it makes sense to me
that it's the Matt Haas and on three of
each sides of the world yeah who end up
getting themselves into trouble but you
two is so patronizing you know I get a
strike for this I dispute it and they
make me go to copyright school they make
me they make me think of quiz when when
I get a strike to traffic school yeah
they make me take a quiz about
copyrights to to start the clock on the
strike expiring and I go to my guy and
I'm how long is the quiz it's like ten
questions but it's it's so patronizing
where it's like okay you're gonna make
me take this copyright quiz did you make
whoever's filing the claim take a
copyright quiz cuz I think they should
take a freaking quiz before they claim
my video guarantee nah it's like dude I
fought a lawsuit for fair use why are
you making me take a copyright quiz why
are you giving me a strike I get a
strike even though I disputed it I'm
defending myself against parasitic
copyright claims and DMCA takedowns I
know what I'm doing why am I getting
punished
like I did something wrong getting a
strike and why am I being forced to go
to copyright school when I'm defending
myself but they should get a strike it's
like okay you want to claim someone your
ass go to copyright school it's
ridiculous you know why should all the
burden be on the defendant that's true
why why is that a strike or defending
myself so the whole thing was just so
annoying it really is you know it makes
it feel like um the tone of the
situation from the beginning luckily I'm
educated on this and I know about it
but if you are not initiated or you're
not educated it makes it automatically
from the getting feel like you're wrong
and they're right I think that's why the
first time was so scary and we were so
stressed throughout the whole lawsuit
because we like logically it made sense
that we were in the right but you just
don't know well there's there was never
a precedent yeah we just didn't know
what to expect you hope that the judge
gets it and you're confident that the
law is on your side and yeah and and
thankfully you know but it it all makes
you feel like you're not and the right
yeah the stakes were very high in on
that lawsuit so but yeah now now having
been through that I'm very confident
yeah but I can see it the way that it
plays out it feels like the defendant is
wrong you are punished they are
empowered they try to steal your money
and you say no like okay we'll move your
video and then you get a strike and you
have to go to school also they are like
so wrong about it what are they gonna
argue that we're taking money from them
like people are watching our show to see
their video finding a stop is if we send
them more traffic end of a two hour
podcast how do we give them visibility
we send them more traffic so if anything
they can even argue like lots of money
so right that one of the crux of
copyright infringement lawsuits is that
we're stealing their yeah Anacortes
traffic there were competition but that
cop dirty when you're talking about to
our podcast is
very intimate to our podcast there's
just no room at all
we're there it's impossible that we're
stealing their organic traffic yeah
anyway these guys whatever I just it's
stupid they should be punished I'm gonna
beat them they're gonna disappear it's
gonna come back after ten days or
whatever and you know I'm the one that
has to eat [ __ ] and they just and
they're what what is that you know well
so they they actually did the whole DMCA
thing yes right so basically it goes
like this Dan they said I want to take
your money I said no you can't have my
money and then they said okay so we'll
remove the video right and then I did be
a the DMCA and yet right so I mean no
fraudulent DMCA I mean that is
punishable by like a huge fine right I
mean like fraudulent DMCA you have to
prove that they had a bad faith DMCA you
would have to find evidence
right well the thing is the wording of
the DMCA again so prohibitive because it
says you have to have a good faith yeah
knowledge our good faith opinion that
it's in violation of copyright so to be
able to argue that they have that they
didn't have good faith you have to like
prove that they knew it was fair use
which yeah obviously that's pretty hard
to do unless like subpoena their their
email location or what a little absurd
at that point yeah so bummer it's pretty
[ __ ] how that all works
I'm surprised man I have it's been a
while since I haven't had a license
holder just let go of the claim yeah
they almost always back down when we
dispute stuff and they have nothing to
gain they have nothing to gain by by
removing the video yeah that's what it's
just vindictive that's what always
surprised me when people do that that's
what Matt Haase did yeah so the whole
podcast episode is down for how long
like oh like I don't know it'll be up in
like a week or something back up and
then their next their only recourse from
that point is to sue us
you know it's funny the Matt ha video
that was originally removed it's still
down
it's like hello we won the lawsuit
idiots the judge said that spare use can
you bring the video back up it's a
thought oh well it's never happened
before you know but it's like hey is
this still in violation of copyright
YouTube are you sure about that
outrageous so in summary the three beats
slide is sliding their way to my life
and looking forward to fighting them in
court in the beautiful state of Hawaii
Matt huh
hidden Matt house asked us for action
talk about that wait we never signed
anything I could talk about him all I
want I don't know what he said he wanted
us to sign something saying that we
couldn't talk about him and we said fu
but that's different from from what from
miles and details of like trying to come
into an agreement like offers I think we
can talk about it I mean we already did
then but whatever I'm not even gonna go
there you guys know that guy's an idiot
Matt Haas the park for it he tried to
sue me for defamation because what was
it like throwing defamation cuz why not
what was it like it's weird that what
you removed or something I don't
remember anymore but it got thrown out
easily
I have you raised it all from my memory
yeah I know it really it's been anyway
shut up to three beats elide who will be
a 3-bit slide or three bitch-slap or
four Beach because they suck three Beach
three Beach it's three being slide yeah
three beats slide bro your shits not
vevo dude you can't put Viva on your
idiot it's not VEVO dumbass you're like
a grown-ass man come on expect that from
a 12 girl but you can't actually put
vivo in your [ __ ]
good how do you know man he's signed
what do you think this guy does sign to
a major English bro
what do you think he does for a living
he looks like he just ate a bunch of
bolognaise and didn't wipe his face
got like red all over his face he
manages a pool cleaning supply store or
something like that something like super
mundane okay let's move on from the beat
three Beach slide we should gonna break
oh we're gonna go to break when we come
back we've got we have a lot today we've
got the cringe Trinity and the god
cringe I mean this is you we've got a
holy god Trinity here of cringe that
culminates in the dog abuser made an
apology nerd City made this huge expose
on YouTube the god cringe is a preacher
who's on his phone while speaking in
tongues so good I love that he's
speaking in tongues and he's just
casually on his phone like he's not his
heart is not in it anyway we got a lot
of fun coming up and so do not go away
this is an h3 nation this is an army
right Dan yeah all right yeah you heard
from Dan
Brook linen calm makes the best sheets
in the game let me tell you what's up
Gila when that week comes when those
Brooklyn sheets go on the bed I know
it's gonna be a great week let me tell
you the truth I spend 1/3 of my life
in my bed actually scratching I've had
two thirds of my life in bed and I want
to be making good damn sure that I'm
comfortable
that's what Brooke linen comes in to
making the best sheets the most
comfortable and they go directly to
consumer because that markup if you go
to a like a retail store is in the Seine
I've seen she's go up to $1,000 that's
not the case with Brooklyn because they
sell directly to you and makes you
doesn't need a cut bs middleman they got
35,000 five-star reviews there's a
reason for that
their mission is simply this to make you
comfortable they got luxury sheets
towels bedding and more without the
luxury markup most sheets apparently
have a 300% markup so getting out of
town my sheets are so comfortable my
towels have turned my bathroom into a
spa I cannot recommend Brooklyn
enough go to Brooklyn and calm and I've
got an exclusive offer for you guys to
get 10% off and free shipping when you
use promo code h3 at Brooklyn and calm
they are so confident in their product
that all the sheets comforters and
towels come with a lifetime warranty
damn buy it once for life the only way
to get 10% off and free shipping is used
code promo code h3 at Brooklyn and Comm
that's BR ook Li n en comm promo code h3
Brooke linen these are the best sheets
ever
Noom is the solution for a fatass like
me to actually get focused and lose
weight fat asses like me have tried
everything and I'm not saying that to be
derogatory I'm just being on I'll talk
about myself you're beautiful and
voluptuous I'm a fatass Noom addresses
the issues that we have problem with
dieting what they address is the this
the psychological issues the this
physical issues the social issues they
build a community where you where people
keep you accountable and you have a
trainer who talks to you and keeps you
on budget keeps you it teaches you it's
an educational tool it counts your
calories and it kate's you about the
food that you're eating on a day to day
basis if you're eating avocado or
whole-wheat toast or maybe you have a a
bowl of cereal and they're gonna tell
you basically how much of what you can
eat to to hit your weight goal and
you're gonna learn a lot too about
what's good and what's not because
because they have a write-up on every
food so it's education it's psychology
they are building a support system to
make sure that fat asses like me can
lose weight you guys may notice that
I've lost a couple of pounds red ELA
that's thanks to noon I'm checking in
I'm keeping updated I'm not what are you
talking about new it's a it's designed
to change the habit of users and learn
to develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses it's based
on cognitive cognitive behavioral
approach it's not a diet
it's healthy and easy to stick to way of
life if this sounds like something that
you might be interested in if you want
to change the way that your relationship
is with food you don't have to change it
all in one day small steps make big
progress sign up for your trial today at
noon and oom comm /h 3 what do you have
to lose guys except weight visit new
moms /h free to start your trial today
that's noon dot-com / HD the last weight
loss program you'll ever need
so set up for your trial today at noon
and oom comm /h 3
quip is a toothbrush that has
revolutionized my brushing experience is
a product that I loved and endorsed
personally and it's changed the game for
me and a lot of people in the brushing
domain I love it so much
brush community whip sensitive
vibrations and built in time by brushing
for the dentist recommended two minutes
with the 30 second pulsing to ensure
even clean in each quadrant of your
mouth quad automatically delivers
brushes to every three months for clean
new bristles right on schedule it's got
a sleek intuitive design that is simple
to use and comes with a travel cap that
doubles as a mirror mount these
thoughtful features make brushing
something you can actually want to do
twice a day good habits matter to live a
healthier life guys it's important to
take care of your teeth and quit makes
it easier and more enjoyable to do that
and not to mention it's got the soft
bristle has it doesn't harm my gums at
all and that's something that I'm just
obsessed with you need to maintain your
gums that will not grow back people and
quit I endorse for that quit starts at
just 25 dollars as well and you get your
first refill pack for free at get quick
calm /h Street this is a simple way to
take better care of your mouth support
the show and getting toothbrush that
will float you all the way to Valhalla
and you'll be the biggest name in the
tooth brushing community quip starts at
just 25 dollars and you get your first
refill pack for free at get quick calm
/hre there's a simple way to improve
your oral hygiene become the biggest
name in the brushing community and help
support our show at the same time so go
to g ET q UIP comm / h3 and get your
first refill pack for free so go right
now to g ET q UIP comm / h3 quip starts
at just $25 you get your first refill
refill pack for free at get quick calm /
h3
Eva have you ever bought something
online and find out you could have
gotten it for less it's worse than a
messy poop true
not to mention once it happens you feel
like you could be overpaying every time
you buy something online luckily I have
honey the free browser extension that
saves you time and money when shopping
online
honey scans the internet for coupons and
other discounts then like magic it
automatically applies the one with the
biggest savings to your cart at checkout
it knows about every coupon code sale or
discount and over 20,000 sites like
Amazon Macy's j.crew Domino's Sephora
Target and more and in this case Baby
Gap you know you spent $230 a baby gap
yeah now it oh well more like 160 you
say the 70 bucks yeah that's a passive
it just passively scans the Internet
yeah you checkout and it's like you just
saved it's just shopping for Theodore
and I've turned it on you know it feels
amazing and let me tell you it feels
like a clean life when you save with
honey it's there's a reason it has over
10 million users and let me tell you
this number it's saved over a billion
dollars for it's 10 million users
passively for free you got nothing to
lose there's no reason not to be using
honey it's free to install and easy to
install just two clicks on your computer
get honey for free I'd join honeycomb
slash h3 that's join honey calm slash h3
you didi mega doodoo we are back with
the godlike cringe Trinity the Holy
Spirit the mother and the son do you
guys remember the dog abuser this girl
who spit on her top and accidentally
uploaded it to YouTube and it was like
computer a whole beautiful chain well
she finally is back she has disappeared
and come back with apology not a good
ratio on that it
33000 down 1.70 second chances on you
too well here won't you listen no no I
mean that's true people are cut throw
these days oh but you listen and you
tell me a message for you welcome for me
yes
the comments are brutal it says it's
comedy category C they said comment yet
cuz this video's a joke all right so you
guys tell me what you think
[Music]
Chris either audio real quick I want to
say thank you to anyone who hasn't
reached out no no problem in this
discussion over the past month or so I
just want to genuinely say thank you
because I think as a society it is so
important that we continue to talk about
things we feel need to be talked about
thank you for bringing it up to my
attention it's the worst it's the worst
it's the worst I hate that it's so
patronizing yeah thank you or small for
expressing your concern thank you your
default - yeah it's the work dude it's
the work don't do that
also nobody believes that you're
actually grateful yeah we everyone
ruined - thank you for ruining my life
thank you thank you for cello thank you
for spending on my dog who spits on
their dog nobody she does okay I was
concerned
thank you for that thank you you're
welcome
my pleasure want to apologize to anyone
who was offended it has never [ __ ] a
great apology apologize to anyone who
was offended yeah which is kind of your
you're not a non-apology cuz it's like
sorry that you were offended not not
mindful mm-hmm right so she's kind of
hitting the the she's batting up like a
banker no yeah she's got the thank you
for bringing to my attention and the
apologies to anyone offended let's see
where it goes from here try to justify
my actions YouTube apology looks like a
whole genre there's a lot of them have I
made an apology video intentionally yeah
when did I make an apology video oh I
did for The Wall Street Journal yeah
yeah that's the first that comes to mind
yeah right yeah that one was necessary
[Laughter]
okay I guess we've all the wrongs all
better
maybe yeah boy I didn't know God we got
thanks you thank yous we got apologies
mmm tears tears for you I like that I
like that one I like that title it's
like Oh for me and I never will
I don't like this positon what I have
done however is I've taken this time
this past month or so to further educate
myself in animal training and in animals
in general like she does your dog she's
like so is it okay to spit on the dog oh
it's not okay doesn't mean that I'm the
leader of the pack mm-hmm I'm just
trying to alpha him a volunteer at a
local animal welfare organization and so
I'm really happy and excited about that
hopefully you're not spitting on dogs
there let's keep you away from dogs
since the matter I have invested in
professional dog training so much I just
imagined it was spitting on her dog I
promise you relationship is strong
where's the dog the trainer is
absolutely amazing
where's the dog and it's just perfect
it's exactly what what I needed contact
with LAPD since the matter and honestly
every day I'm just trying to continue to
better myself as a dog owner okay what's
with those pauses does anyone else have
a problem with no I agree I think she's
trying to do it in one take yeah I mean
yeah she's not she doesn't have any cuts
so I think she might gets off the cuff
yeah obviously I think she probably
filmed this like you know dozens of
times as we saw in the in the in the one
she uploaded first spitting on her dog
she takes stuff a lot so I think that
she she I mean she disappeared for like
a month she's probably just doing takes
of this the whole time this is the one
I just want to encourage you that if you
see me in public I want you to come up
to me
stop that's a weird one what are you
talking about you know me and just by
coming up and talk India on the street
[Music]
or other public figures even who have
commented on the situation I pray I pray
that one day we can meet because I would
love to show you who I really am bro
what are you invited you want to hang
out you won't become like a my best
friend
once she ghosted us right yeah you yeah
I reached out to you and you ghosted me
so I don't bring I don't arraign yeah
leave her I
that's so true I opened the door to a
conversation with her and she goes to me
she's just better pray harder she goes
to you before we even talked about it on
the podcast or really publicly other
than just write that one tweet so mmhmm
yeah not buying it
you know the what's that one book pray
eat love versus pray eat spit I don't
think it will but in the off chance that
it does get monetized she tried the
monetize it tried to monetize it or not
but I'm gonna donate that's I think she
was expecting yet like 10 million will
go if this video does get monetize just
because I know people are going to ask
and okay I don't think this video will
be monetize but in the off-chance ain't
over she keep talking about the money
they donated to an animal welfare animal
welfare organization in Southern
California
last thing I want to say before I go is
thank you so much to everyone who has
continued to support me doesn't affect
many of study said I love you so much
and
it's just meant the world to me over
this time so I just want to say thank
you and again I want to say thank you to
everyone who has commented on this
situation and has spoken out about us
that are important to them and things
that matter to that is thank you you're
welcome
besides that lots of thank yous very
grateful did she wait so we're worrying
Q for listening where's your dog there
you go what do you think are we are we
buying it it's a pretty bad one
I mean she I don't know it's just kind
of like you just [ __ ] up you know and
there's just not much you can say right
now you just gotta take it you just
gotta take some time and with such an
epic fail dude you spit on your dog it's
the weirdest thing you could do and the
way it happened that she uploaded the
unedited her hold they're all channels
about her happy-go-lucky relationship
with the dog one for the anals he knows
of youtube a well there you go you guys
be the judge for yourselves does the dog
abuser spitting girl is she sincere does
she deserve to be curved to continue to
live on this planet or should she be
blasted into outer space and never to be
seen or heard from again because what I
think a lot of people on the internet
would like to deal with her know that
they cancel blast them in outer space to
spend out the rest of their days we
haven't so that's the that's the I would
guess I would call that the holy ghost
of the cringe train man because her
YouTube channel is a ghost town oh nice
like that and the next one in the fringe
pants this is why found through Chris
D'Elia
he said if you see he said on Twitter if
I see anyone wearing these I'm gonna
punch them in the faces and well he's
got a point
so they say tech insider this wearable
chair could
change how we work and travel you've
gotta be good at my crime you can't be
sick inside they're like this is some
kind we're a revolutionary tech this
they can't be serious I mean so it's so
it's like a harness around your waist
and there's two legs that that rest on
the back side of your legs and when you
sit it turns into a chair but it looks
so cumbersome and frankly dangerous as
well this music what do you think yeah
this wearable chair will allow you to
sit anywhere yeah can you imagine the
guys got like a whole what bro you look
like such a tool does that makes it an
extension of your body how you gonna sit
on the bus yeah takes up the wheelchair
spot dude had to sit to grab a drink bro
why don't you jump off the ledge work it
doesn't even look comfortable
no it's called deluxe deluxe it's
lightweight and portable dude stop can
you imagine anyone actually walking with
that this is madness it's made of
aerospace grade aluminum okay great
why is sitting so important all of a
sudden you got to give up your look and
you can spark up to 285 pounds no it's
okay Shaq wants one of these you can
have it do you do dude if it's so true
like Chris said I mean if you see
someone walking around with this then
you you you need to be outcast from
society you should be chastised and
removed from society that's a good point
why is sitting so important yeah do you
like the right I mean you're gonna look
like this person there that looks so
uncomfortable dude encourages good
posture reduce the risk of back pain oh
there you go you look there's always
somewhere to sit and courage is being
punched in the face reduces amount of
friends mm-hmm just looked at up 215
bucks
for one of those Oh God can we buy one
so it looks like it was only sold in a
limited quantity because it was like a
Kickstarter mm-hmm
so someone actually thought this was a
good idea I mean they raised thousand
and forty three thousand dollars the
creator says it can change how we use
our workspace shut the [ __ ] up we have
chairs dude I like how it's the
creator's say yeah no one else believes
someone else's dude that cannot be
comfortable how we commute yeah you
can't sit on that thing oh my god do you
understand what a spectacle you would be
if you were to walk through that thing
what happens when you're going the Train
you can't say it you have to use your
seat your poopy see it what happens if
you got a pee why are you why are you so
desperate to sit like that's what I
don't understand yeah so we can't buy
this bin well they they succeeded in
their Kickstarter so it might be coming
soon can you see if we can buy it I I
mean it it looks like it was a the
Kickstarter was it says the starting
price is 186 and they raised the price
I'm seeing on an article from Digital
Trends 215 but well go ahead and go to
the web site see if we can buy one of
these so I'm gonna go yeah all right
what I would like to do is have Zach's
or sorry Ian setting this as I run them
over on the Gatsby pre-order now hold on
pre-order we'll never see that thing so
that's the cringe spirit once you walk
around in public with this thing and you
get thrown off the bridge you were
sitting in front of you'll become a
spirit I'm trying my best
I like it thank you wait and they hold
on on indiegogo which is another
crowdfunding website they raised a
hundred and twenty five thousand there
so baton were these scammers they have
separate starving is when you can do
that like double double dip double dip
my god
and that's who for scanning the perk
yeah and the perk on this one it was
$400 you donate to get a set of it to
d.school these nobody's ever getting
listened to how much of a scammer ease
these Kickstarter's are they go we have
a two hundred dollar product if you give
us four hundred you will get no equity
in the company but we'll give you a
chair worth $200 what how about you make
something that's good enough that you
could create it of its own merit
I hate Kickstarter yeah it's a there's a
lot of nonsense on there I mean some
good things have come from it I wouldn't
just say across the board it's awful but
I think it's 90% scam yeah totally
because there's no accountability they
can raise as much money as they want
they keep the money there's there's no
accountability oh the real problem is
people that just keep giving money to
people on Kickstarter and it's insane
people how did this tech insider Twitter
thing also I think cuz people I'm so
stupid
okay yeah you think they're well I think
the the supposed delivered they said
expected delivery in December so like
this started like a year ago but
supposedly people are gonna start
getting them pretty soon so I guess
they're getting more buzz I think it's a
joke that it was so explosive on Twitter
but Dan if you can get me on the wait
list I'll pay $500 for a $200 chair why
not get me in that you guys want one we
don't need chairs anymore we're
revolutionizing the workspace I'll see
what I can do see we can get if we love
it we're like dude we will have to we'll
have to make an apology video absolutely
if you're if you're driving you have to
take it on and off every time you get in
and out of your car just so that you can
sit for five minutes when you're waiting
for the bus because you're too lazy to
lean they're selling a team pack a pair
of five pairs perfect there's five how
much 1,600 Wow
I can't do that
I can't do that now we got to save up I
know you love color options red they got
blue and they got orange what else they
got that's it
and for those reasons I'm out all right
so that's so what are the three parts of
the Train you got the mother we have the
Father the Son and the Holy Ghost we did
the ghost we did the spirit we did plate
I think that's the same thing yes oh so
we did two of the same thing so this one
is the let's just say this one's the is
it the father of the son the chair dad's
got to sit down a lot that's the father
it's the daddy of cringe here we have
this guy Terrence Howard he's like the
star of empire incidentally that was the
show that Jesse small at was on which
was nice all right
there's a bunch of crackpots on there
but get a load of this guy Terrence
Howard shares his innermost thoughts
here's the original war machine - in the
marble right red car I think the second
link is I think the link was originally
timestamp yeah that's my nightmare if I
pop a link in its KTLA talking you made
huge headlines when you said after you
complete these 15 episodes Empire you
got to walk away for a while or forever
I mean everyone keeps trying to tell me
don't say it's forever but I spent 37
years pretending to be people so that
people can pretend to watch and enjoy
what I'm doing when I've made some
discoveries in my own personal life with
the science that you know Pythagoras was
searching for I wasn't able to open up
the Flower of Life properly and find the
real wave conjugations that we've been
looking for for 10,000 years
why would I continue you know walking on
water for tips when I've got an entire
generation to teach a whole new world
that's a big remark what do you intend
that's a big remark universe is
expressed in motion let me put it in a
way that you can understand all motion
and the universe are expressed and
opening the flower of life like
someone's virginity I don't know like I
want to see inside this guy's basement
that's it oh wait there's more what do
you do at KTLA let me watch the damn
clip on Tuesday when I received my stars
I'm going to be able to prove
gravity is only an effect and waiting
for the punchline Oh
mysterious yes I'm gonna prove that
gravity doesn't exist
did you also get your star you sir but
he's just but all the big talk about
yeah I've never got an Amy so who cares
you could do whatever you want when you
stand in front that microphone what are
you gonna do yeah ultimately he's just
but her even guy I mean so there you
have a Terrence Howard actually there's
a lot of info here about Terrence he's
invented a new math he called it Terry
ology here's a tweet from 2017 where he
proves that 1 times 1 equals to heal
your heart out
this is the proof of the world of
science and mathematics that one times
one equals two Wow
there you have it I'm not gonna get into
all this but you want to go through all
four pages but it's really written like
I mean dude remote you tell Rita except
for you guys remember the basic laws of
common sense I didn't know there was
basic laws of Commons maybe remember
them as we all know the basic laws of
comment says if a times B equals C that
C must be some product of a and B that
is correct
yeah get in order for 1 times 1 to be 1
the value either A or B has to be
missing from the final product of C
let's not jump the gun just yet C let's
try to add one to both sides of
the equation what I feel like this dude
never took arithmetic and he's like just
finger now he's like math is crazy you
guys I can't get in all this oh my god
but you can't call them a B and C
they're all the same they're all a you
talk about math what I'm looking at is
Terri ology that's actually true they're
all the same number so it's a times a
times a not a b c that's a very good
point you look wow you just ela ology
and his ass we got he goes back even
further interview with Rolling Stones in
2015 revealed he spent years working on
his own logic what you recorded in a
language of symbols called Terri ology I
love that Wow
I love Terri ology it's my favorite
discipline our believes his discovery
will change significantly the way that
mathematics is taught for generations to
come
and if a theorist were around to see his
discovery he would quote lose his mind
yeah I don't know how much I want to
read this a lot of this rolling stone
says Howard's apartment is filled with
objects that resemble building blocks
but are more complex
there are hemispheres cubes tetrahedrons
and flighty wings the students on that
deck some of the objects are as small as
mice others as big as fire hydrants some
are hanging some are freestanding a few
larger ones lit from the inside with LED
twinkle stars
god bless teri ology man I wish
Pythagoras was here to see it
he was around
Pythagoras would lose his he would quote
lose his mind I think I giris was like a
cult leader so arguably yeah I mean like
he was obviously an important
mathematician as well but like yeah
there was like a whole like ancient
Greek cult around him and stuff and it's
some weird [ __ ] well back off and we got
a new Terry ology which one highlight it
Howard's everything so is this
Oh what here he tweeted out crazy is as
crazy does do the math okay what math
are we doing exactly why bet you feel
like an idiot now Ethan look at that
crazy is as crazy does do the math
[ __ ] I mean he's got a pass it's
really nice-looking yeah but you're not
doing the math I this is the proof that
also I love that his life mission is to
prove that one times one equals two yeah
like okay so what so what do we you know
means that gravity is not real right
that's what that direct correlation yeah
it's teri ology and now we've got the
granddaddy cringed God yeah who's
actually a preacher this is the fourth
we we've gone beyond the Trinity no cuz
we did the Trinity but then but then we
did though this is like the unity this
is yeah this is yeah so you know I've
always longed criticized these these
mega preachers you know I'm not I'm not
a critical of religion in general I am
an agnostic person but these guys are
total scammers these guys are total
frauds and this is just so fantastic the
the the dichotomy of him speaking in
tongues to his reception and meanwhile
casually as possible browsing what can I
can only presume his Twitter on his
phone I mean just enjoy this clip I pray
I pray I pray healing healing healing it
I pray I pray I pray deliverance
deliverance deliverance deliverance
deliverance mmm yes Lord yes Lord yes
Lord yes Lord yes Lord yes Lord yes Lord
yes Lord
i'ma come back up a catechist Winnicott
that's how I talk to Theodore doesn't it
now he picked up his palm now he's on
his phone have your way and he's leaned
into his phone so he can read and he
stopped even trying to do the thumb
because he's he's focused on his sponsor
he just starts going and so much is
wiping the table town he's just looking
at his phone he's obviously just focused
on his phone so he toned down the
tongues like a lot be focusing on God
when you're doing cause it's almost like
if he was having a stroke you can
alright cool
this is my favorite this is what I'm
gonna do when I text you know so we go
so he goes that's how I talk to theorise
I didn't know I was talking tongues I
had I get it good oh good
he gets all lazy with that all things
are possible with God give me or you
want to talk in tongues neck do you say
biblioteca
hit me with some holy [ __ ] Holy Ghost
Holy Ghost
oh he goes Chile keep that Cup mmm
speak to my mama everybody getting
everybody do the oh Jesus Lord Jesus
Lord everybody open your mic and speak
in tongues right so was that a curse
speak you back to twirl joel osteen
rikki-tikki rikki-tikki Shakalaka oh oh
hold on Oh J just made a new tweet for
the world
hey to the world it's me yours truly oh
yeah I can take a negative guy okay
everybody now that you've been touched
by God
go ahead and pass around the chow
negative negative negative
they don't call the chip a tip jar in
charge do they go ahead and pass around
the tip jar
hi I believe a [ __ ] they have a name
with it so you got a fancy name for the
tip jar Oh shake it will God our crack
power cards paralyzed I could be a
preacher this is yeah it's [ __ ] yeah
we watched that little bit one with her
[Music]
and there's a dude wiping on whatsapp
she sees the mess with the priests a
weird sound there you have it you guys
seen any of that show righteous
gemstones no no what is that huh you
find this amusing it's uh it's got Danny
McBride I think it's his show actually I
think he wrote it John Goodman's in it
they're uh they're televangelists oh
that sounds great yeah it's it's good
what would you give it at a ten uh I'm
only three episodes in so far I probably
give it like a seven or an eight okay I
don't okay I like eastbound and down
more because this is the same like
creative team I don't know if you guys
ever watch yeah wash I watched a little
bit yeah but but again I've only seen a
little bit and John Goodman is so good
in it Zak can you pull the sound bite of
him going I already told them we got
Zach that was pretty slick how you hit
down with that honestly appreciate you
got email Wow
Hey alright so Kanye do we want to do
Kanye watch in you want to come out here
and talk about yes we do kind of an Ian
has been so quiet this week yeah dad I
was like and it's what closer you died
no no Kanye's new album just didn't come
out yet okay oh dude you need to get you
need oh coming here and talk to us I've
got a piece so bad every picture that
Kim Kardashian posts on Instagram all
the comments are just worse the album
morally amo where is Jake they call it
cuz it's Jesus is king oh they Jesus is
king - call James sit on the right hand
side bouncing that right check other
chair oh no in the intern has entered
the studio I'm noticing first of all
that your hat there's a paper covering
up your hat doing like that yeah I don't
want to represent what it normally says
what does it say
it's a kind of your head yeah so why is
the Hat covered because he betrayed me
how did he betray you
I was bamboozled I was hoodwinked he
ruined my weekend and have you eaten
like in Lois you look at healthy bro you
look pale come on I haven't shaved I'm
feeling out of it so what how did he how
did he betray you if you type in right
now yeah open a tab type in Kanye West
calm Oh
his official website which he hasn't
changed he hasn't updated it okay this
is a tracklist Jesus is king yep those
are the songs September 27 yes
this album doesn't exist oh so do you
okay so you were waiting you were super
excited for the release and that went
and gone and that really messed that
really did disturb your your balance of
your life frankly my mental health is
what you think you what are you doing a
kanye album comes out like how like tell
me about the prop like your your you
know how would you say ritual so last
year when one came out it was I was here
at the show it ended I
drove to the ocean and put headphones on
and watch the Sun go down as I listened
to it what album was that I was called
yay were you gonna do that with this one
no I think I was gonna go like probably
at the top of the Hollywood sign and go
watch the sunrise yeah no one they've
ruined it oh it's very mess that always
like such a production it's so it's a
big deal it's like a holiday
yeah it was like I was like great
Friday's Christmas and then someone went
Christmas is canceled and you're you're
part of the community so so how is the
community response respond good Oh I've
watched all these people go through the
five stages of grief pretty heavily do
you think that this is a normal and
healthy relationship you have with Kanye
because it seems a little extreme to me
not anymore I feel like I'm downshifting
after this yeah I think you should
downshift yeah you noticed yes it's it's
time and he clearly doesn't like I don't
know maybe he dies but it feels like he
doesn't really give that much of a [ __ ]
about his fans do you feel like you
can't wear Nike shoes now yes you're
worried you're not no no not you have
Taylor you have some kind of Taylor
Swift March you brought for us guys a
gift as protest you've got one
reputation are you I am now I'm I'm the
proud owner of a reputation so thank you
very much to Ian
yep this is from 2013 this is vintage
merch and that's some bad March have to
say born I'm a born-again swifty I'm
moving on yeah I feel like you could
rock that by the way how do you feel
about Taylor Swift music I don't mind
her now in tell me it I'm fascinated but
perplexed still about this relationship
yeah what Kanye music I mean how did you
ever I mean what is going on here why
why is this so meaningful to you I mean
really take down tea
what's going on I feel like it's just a
lot of stuff all combined just like how
he kind of does what he wants does his
own thing he says a lot of motivational
stuff you really sucked me in like that
but I feel this weekend like what he was
doing with that pastor he's checking his
phone talk and then Jesus asking Jesus
Jesus buy my merch he sold like probably
hundreds of thousands of dollars worth
of merch over the weekend take that new
album yeah people have how much it cost
like sweaters like it'd be a yeah like a
crewneck for like 175 buy buy buy no
actually doesn't exist but that come out
well what I heard was that September
27th that the album was like not even
close to finished yeah I was here we
were doing the show yeah and then Ian
was like so despondent and then it
didn't come out and then Kim went she
tweeted something said sorry guys just
finishing some mixing it's actually
gonna come out to 29th why is Kim no she
yeah he's off to quit his kind of Yoko
Ono yelling it a little bit don't you at
least she tried to communicate right
though he doesn't talk to us at all and
the heat Sunday came like Friday
Saturday Sunday that's like all I did
was wait for this thing all day Sunday
do not make any plans you can't leave
the house no I was locked in I was
locked in and then he did listening
parties played apparently something for
people called eh there's like low
quality recordings I haven't touched any
of those but apparently it sounds very
unfinished so would you rather him just
release it or fit he should have
finished it I should have finished it
and then because he did this last year
that's the thing so why do you come up
with a date last August the exact day
this is why it's the worst
last August he said September 27th 2018
my albums coming out and then it just
didn't
and then Kim said oh sorry guys actually
Black Friday is when it comes out and
then we never heard from him again
Black Friday came to the know oh my god
and then August did he still works for
that one
he sold like stuff on his website that
said album included and never got it
whoa really what I feel like it could be
yeah that's definitely criminal so and
those fans are still fans I don't know
where those people are maybe there's
things you don't mind that it does if
calling you [ __ ] on your mom's
that's a little bit if Kanye's [ __ ] your
mom's Cheerios would you still be a fan
be [ __ ] on your doorstep that was like
[ __ ] you in my doorstep yeah would you
cherish that [ __ ]
I'd probably box it up you cherish put
it on eBay you could get that on eBay
yeah you and so that you know but see I
am kind of annoyed I'm like I'm not like
oh but cuz I do see those people to
online that are like guys you all need
to relax it's coming I believe in him
and all this weird stuff and I'm kind of
like I'm like no I'm like pissed off of
this guy do you ever do you ever have a
concerns that you may be too
too involved in Kanye to wrapped up
think your welfare is too wrapped up in
what Kanye does probably yeah so well
that's why I was I was like so bummed
out over the weekend is because I'm a
very as you guys could probably attest
I'm very like even-keeled sort of
low-energy most the time there's not a
lot of stuff done like super into mmm so
when the one of those very few things
like says like shits on my corpse
essentially when yes and says I don't
give a [ __ ] it was kind of like wow
that's mm but you know that's whatever
I'm fine I'm totally not bad had you
called him crying what that true
did I what caused that cry no you know
we had a conversation what are you
talking about no he's lying here guys
well I have to I have to tell you guys
okay when we're on the air I expect
brutal honesty yes we're here to
entertain you got to pour your soul out
here for every
to see so I think you calls that no Zack
are you lying
I mean I wanted him to call me okay so
yeah oh my god Bo's lay the soundbite of
the hit him with a sack you can't not
and not muddy the rivers but I would I
would believe that you work did you ever
cry no over Kanye no I was just annoyed
I was very annoyed this weekend okay I
didn't cry I didn't cry I promise would
you make love to come would you go gay
for Kanye so if he said you know if that
do this and I'll drop the album you know
I got some stuff to think about
so what kind of Mitchell act are we
talking about like cool like are we
talking about fellatio Ella please and
not in this scenario Thank You Congress
and Kanye has cheated as cheated hasn't
he
oh yeah well no no no he's got a thing
for white chicks and I mean you're a
white guy and you're a nice little twink
probably but let me just it would you
would it be fellatio or would you be
down to take it from him you know when
you're in the heat of the moment it's
really hard to say when things get
caught up you know it's things would you
all roll in and Wow Ian's taking all the
way that's pretty serious no I'm but
seriously though I think I'm Stephanie
do consider switching to someone else
like not because I think I'm pulling out
entirely with the whole we were
fantasized sexually about going us no
I'm just I'm just curious would you let
him pee on you I don't like urine I
don't go the bathroom well that's
granted are Kelly's the hpn on everyone
in prison he's getting peed on in prison
he's totally getting paid on right now
all the prison it's all coming down on
well II and III wish I had something
more wise to say for you do you ever
start to like speak in tongues when
you're waiting for the album in how are
you ever gonna enter a relationship with
somebody like you have
I feel like it's hard to explain all
this stuff you're gonna have to find a
girl who has the same reverence for
Kanye when that is remembered The
Bachelor we're in the process we're in
the process yeah well we narrowed it
down wait aren't we doing the finale
next week yeah I mean we are I guess our
schedule shuffle yeah but I don't think
I just don't think those girls are on
the same level I think they're there
they want to be but what's what station
I wouldn't want them to be that because
it's not healthy behavior
I recognize that so yeah I know I'm
mature I'm a mature individual I just
you know this is have you ever like
drifted apart from friends because
they're not into Kanye no no I'm not one
of those that gets in you know arguments
about him or anything I don't yeah that
would be a problem if you know if your
relationships and we're being strained
yeah yeah cuz he said I understand he's
like a controversial figure not a lot of
people like him and that's fine cuz he
does a lot of stupid [ __ ] posters on
your wall no you don't have any Kanye
memorabilia um I mean like merch and
things like that not on the wall or
anything no use tissue why well he a
framed photograph above my bed the hat
you're wearing is from the listening
party yeah dude he's throwing a
screenplay about Kanye's life about a
biopic yeah that does exist like he's
all about Kanye West I saw some yeah
it's funny cuz I'll sometimes I'll look
I probably shouldn't say this sometimes
I'll look at the like the fan forum the
one I got kicked out of and they'll
mention me sometimes and they'll be like
yo [ __ ] this guy he doesn't know
anything about Kanye
that's [ __ ] I'm like don't even try
me we did a Kanye off I would destroy
and right that we have to do a pony off
we have to do a Kanye off we did we
should actually have a huge Kanye step
to him though if there's any massive
Kanye fans and there's what about the
Kanye podcast yeah we can reach out to
those guys those guys are great let's
get someone to call in if you think that
you are a super fan of Kanye right
into the podcast - a trace reproduction
comm let's have a Kanye off and we'll
just settle this well but for also that
would be great if we could get the
people who banned in what's the name of
the forum you got banned from just tell
me Katy cheese what it's still
so let's reach out to them Dan and let's
just do a battle with one of the admins
for and let's say Dan let's say like
this
if bein wins he becomes an admin if he
loses he never goes on the website again
hmm okay you think it'd be worse than
that if someone came on and humiliated
me in front of everyone I would go into
the desert and you'd never seen our Ian
will never listen to Kanye again I think
I hear Dan calling no thank you
thanks for the thanks you for the Taylor
Swift work and I'm glad to know that
Kanye has free reign over your butthole
I got a piece so bad Wow I was
illuminating Thank You Ian
moving on did you guys know that Belle
Delphine has completely disappeared from
the Internet no after her Instagram page
got banned which was August 1st is that
right somewhere around there she is
completely and totally disappeared that
was her last or last week a tree on post
she's tweeted she a few days since then
even on patreon she's completely
disappeared and her patreon followers
have dwindled to half Wow
during this during this whole big bath
gamer girl bathwater what happened she
had like she was everywhere she had all
the support in the world and she's she's
just extra feeing away because she's
just disappeared
and it's such a shame I miss I miss
having her content to look at like like
that octopus one I mean that's good
content so when I guess I got her banned
right
no was the no on Instagram it was just a
bunch of people reporting her all these
insoles oh that was because it was like
a dead animal no that's on YouTube that
[ __ ] still up on you too much
I checked it yesterday he's got five
million views so I went over to her
store which I've now learned it's
actually a fake somebody her actual
stores not online which is crazy what's
the name of her where is it what's the
name of a real website Dan oh shoot I
forget I figured it out last night but
since it's a dead link I didn't include
Alfie mom well anyway her real stores
offline which makes me wonder if she got
into legal trouble because shipping
bathwater I don't think is legal hmm
yeah I don't especially internationally
yeah use bathwater or well on this
website she's selling urine and I was
that crazy but it turns out that um but
then thousand dollars that it's not real
and which is hilarious because I almost
bought some dudes urine I was like ten
thousand that's a good deal look at this
chew gum gamer water so this is just
some dude scamming people yes oh yeah
and it's the game the SEO cuz uh if you
google Belle Delphine store I mean this
is the first result and it looks
official and checked so yeah yeah but
her site's offline so I mean but but at
any rate um I was really excited by her
pee that's not her fans are upset
because she hasn't posted any new
content on her patreon in months Dan's
got an imager here dan actually bought a
membership to her patreon so that we can
get the inside scoop there's a
conversation we found I think he wants
you to delete it to have people unaware
full of hope and to keep them subscribed
what is this referring to six days and
haven't heard from her yeah this is old
yeah well I mean not that'll a few days
ago oh yes yeah but again there people
are it seems very contentious people are
saying oh she messaged me and she's
making a comeback soon but then other
people are like prove it and they don't
prove it and so it just it all seems
like it's just a bunch of people trying
to scam each other well what's what's
interesting in me is that she had like
over 4,000 patreon so now she has 2,000
what's interesting really there's still
2,000 people paying in the hopes that
she comes back yeah but I'm surprised
how ballistic it went and then all gone
she disappeared if I'm paying for Part
II I'm not getting there I'm not man you
know what I'm saying I got a knock I
gotta get my nut dude [ __ ] yeah no and
why did she disappear her last post on
social media was this post on Twitter
she claims everything so graphic I can't
show ya but she said it's a picture of
her in a bikini actually this is this is
actually safe to show but her banner is
not so no matter what I can't show to
you but it's her and a bikini and a pool
it says me on holiday before I got food
poisoning had to get an ambulance to a
Greek hospital then fly back home early
and that was the last we heard from her
Wow no posts silence Oh for over two
months total silence Instagram banned
gone from patreon snapchat everywhere
and I'm and I'm really wondering what
happened because Dan had a theory that
maybe she realized that she needs to
move on and I was like no way dude she
hit the jackpot she was always on the
news yes she was doing the gamer girl
water she was all in dude there's no way
she doubles her payment you're right on
something League will happen I think it
might have been a legal thing cuz why
would she just disappear no comment
anywhere she became so big it was Thor
as Aaron was talking to everywhere the
late-night guys how were certain it was
the buzz everywhere so all the sudden
the UK government's like you're selling
what in the mail like the
Royal Mail you can't send mmm you Spath
water b or urine or whatever the LSU
sending chewed gum I don't know spit in
our case spit exactly I mean I didn't
report or anything I mean she didn't
sell it to me today yeah we didn't buy
anything
I don't know but oh I hate to think that
I had anything to do with that tan don't
bring that up
sorry well at any rate that's my own
that's my only gas is that is that
there's some kind of legal issue like I
said in the patreon there's buzz and
she's she's well won't come back so I
guess watching closely and I will I'll
reach out to her and ask her say hey Dad
Belle I was just wondering if you're
okay and also I am interested in
purchasing the urine I understand that's
a fake but if you'd be willing to sell
me your urine I ate ten thousand dollars
worth well what do you think should I
buy Belle's urine or the tank mobility
scooters the tank exactly drink the
urine
no man yellow it's pun intended I would
love to ride that tank mobility yeah but
when you love to [ __ ] get a mouthful
of bells here no no all right here's the
solution hey boy both Zac's got it drink
the urine well the tank and it spills
all over him anyway
a lot of controversy Belle Delphine we
wish you well we hope you're well we
miss you and we can't wait for your
triumphant return hopefully I mean it's
just a bleak or world without her bro
did you say that uh at her peak she had
4,000 I think more yeah more people yeah
because what I learned when I signed up
for it because you can I couldn't get to
the comments it was all locked unless
you're a subscriber or whatever so the
lowest here is a dollar but what I did
that unlocked the comments but that
doesn't actually give you anything to
get her content is 25 bucks yeah for the
premium snapchat 4,000 subs or whatever
yeah and it's twenty-five hundred
thousand a month
that's what I'm saying there's no way
yeah exactly that's why we're surprised
there's no way she just walks away from
that yeah you know I mean unless she
made her bag and she's just done you
know no no no way
she's making she's just taking Polaroids
snap she works like 10 minutes a day she
making $100,000 a most you know what
come on
this is she's built she's worked all
this time she's trolled the whole
internet it's culminated and her finally
arriving yeah she's not she made it
she's nominated for a pornhub award god
bless her I'm voting for her I'll be
there to accept on her behalf know how
long we've been going down about two
hours so we've got the fishy bomb down
what do we got here I'm checking right
now I am sick so how are ya I've got a
little bit of a we got fousey boxing
because he got his ass beat it was like
just brutal his face is just a mess we
got new dirt said he did this whole
video about demonetized demonetized
words he did this whole study that was
really interesting and we've got the dog
abuser apology we did that the Joker
movie everyone's freaking out about
oh yeah inside right yeah and what do
you think about Joker I thought it was
all right it wasn't good enough - hmm
all the hysteria but everyone's saying
oh but it's really good it just wasn't
that good to me dude that's what I think
I think it's just probably a movie but
the hysteria around it is insane I can't
believe what I was reading well
apparently it's a beautiful months ago
at the Venice Film Festival and it won
an award there received an eight-minute
standing ovation and just win an award
Wynette they won the award the won the
top prize right so this this is
interesting the the movie is being
slammed by most critics yet yet the user
reviews are very good so you have a
disconnect between the critics and the
users which you see sometimes it hasn't
necessarily been getting slammed a lot
of critics have reviewed it favorably
they just always temper it with but it's
dangerous you know wait a little
dangerous movie that's not true I wasn't
brought in Spanish yesterday it's got
69% so I mean it's not great it's not
it's not horrible it's a true yeah I
mean with the way Rotten Tomatoes works
like that means it's generally positive
but the audience score is 93% so really
there's a big difference in the Joker
Metacritic I tend to like movies that
have that disparaging difference
I am definitely curious about the movie
it's kind of a 57 on Metacritic so that
is quite bad and the user scores nine
point one so yeah there's a huge
difference well I think a lot of people
are rating and negatively not
necessarily on the merits of a film but
and these people legitimately think this
is like a dangerous film and so you know
they're they're giving it a thumbs down
just on that basis well so here's some
of the hysteria around it they go much
of the pre-release discussion about joke
are centered on fears of mass shooting
at screenings with the US military
advising service members to be alert and
local police departments posting
officers outside theaters on opening
weekend and families of the 2012 movie
theater shooting in an Aurora where the
guy like Joe dressed up his Joker
[ __ ] dude yeah you know he wasn't
actually dressed up as lead well he dyed
his hair yeah I wasn't doing a Batman
screening and he looked through it was
nuts yeah
anyway the US military issues warnings
about Joker screenings the warning went
out to service members and distributed
of a bulletin from the FBI on the risk
of possible violence alluded to in
social media posts from insell
extremists and the Intel uprising is
here who have made threats to recreate
the theater shootings in Aurora throw
these in cells oh yeah I'm not one
against eugenics but I think I think we
need to cast rise me think we really
need to cast we got it we got to do it
these black pill in cells just need to
have their balls chopped off well
they're not using them yeah yeah he's
like take my balls I never use them
anyway these black filled-in cells how
is this a thing it's like a cult
miss Insull movements [ __ ] weird dude
God you know these Jesus you know these
in cells worship this guy Elliott
Rodriguez who famously shot up UC Santa
Barbara and he released a video in his
car talking about how I don't get when
it's unfair it's unjust so insane and he
went and shot up a bunch of frat girls
and guys and they they idolized him dude
God just that's like vert that's so
crazy that being a vert being such a
pathetic virgin can make you want to
shoot up a frat party you know it's
funny about Elliott Rodriguez he wasn't
even that bad looking it's like you're
just a creep bro uh its Elliott Roger
whatever [ __ ] him Rodriguez is a
journalist so that's not oh you know I'm
talking about but I find that this these
in cells are not bad looking guys
generally they just have such a distort
we can you hear them talk about what
they think they're entitled to it's like
if they just weren't so deep in the
Intel you just acted normally you people
people would want to touch your penis
mm-hmm it's not that complicated dude
anyway they loved uh so the N cells have
been threatening violence at the choker
film which I don't know why because the
Joker is supposed to be someone they
sympathize that you know the Joker
apparently is like an insult in the
movie is that right all right yeah he's
a bit of an in cell and in the narrative
of the film and almost let's say
romanticizes his descent to madness and
violence and so that's why they think
that it's that it's dangerous but I
thought wasn't any different than any
other show about an antihero
you know what I mean then like Breaking
Bad even it's like you don't idolize
Walter White or at least shouldn't
it's like we there's lots of things
about bad people that are like the main
care I'm Ian the Joker is the antithesis
of a villain he is the antithesis of a
villain in the Batman series he's a
psycho he's a psycho murderer antithesis
of a hero you mean but yeah yes thank
you that's what I mean thank you Dad
hit me with that actually if you would
please there yeah honestly there are no
specifics or credible threats at this
time and these events will be continued
to be closely monitored said the NYPD
okay that the family of the Aurora
shooting victims actually sent a letter
to Warner Bros CEO saying I need to see
a picture of I just need to see a job I
don't need to see a picture of him I
just need to see a picture what are they
saying
what are you saying I'm what I'm reading
doesn't make sense I don't need to see a
picture of Holmes I just need to see a
joke or promo and I see a picture of the
killer that sentence doesn't make any
sense
there must be the type over something in
an interview sandy Phillips says that
Joker which centred on the isolated and
mentally ill antihero who became
Batman's eventual arch nemesis is like a
slap in the face she has that she's
concerned about audience connecting to
and even emulating the film's
protagonist in a cultural climate where
mass shootings have become commonplace
my amore is that one person who may be
out there and who knows if it's just one
who's on edge and who was wanting to be
a mass shooter maybe encouraged by this
movie and that terrifies me I mean they
haven't even seen the movie because this
was like from like how do you know that
I mean you could say the same thing
about like I don't know I just I don't
know it seems like a lot of hubbub about
nothing the director Todd Phillips and
Joaquin Phoenix have both been
repeatedly questions regarding their
perception of the film Phillips has
pushed back against the notion of the
movie could be blamed for any realized
violence he says we're making a movie
about a fictional character in a
fictional world ultimately and your hope
is that pee
we'll take it for what it is you can't
play movies for a world that is so
[ __ ] up that anything can trigger it
Aurora is obviously a horrible horrible
situation but even that is not something
you blame on the movie I saw John wick 3
he's a white male and he kills 300
people and everyone's laughing and
hooting hollering why does that movie
get held to a different standard it's
very weird it's it's very weird I mean
it's like a very politically motivated
strange thing
Phoenix walked out of an interview when
asked whether Joker might inspire a
copycat behavior I feel bad for Joaquin
Phoenix he's like he gave it his all in
this in this and now it's like what
didn't well he's like dude what did I do
he was asked if he was worried that the
film might persuasively end up inspiring
exactly the kind of people it's about
with potentially tragic results the
question caused Phoenix to mutter why
would you no no the interview before
walking out only to return an hour later
Phoenix said that the question had it
crosses my before and then asked what an
intellectual intelligent answer would
have sounded like and another the actor
said I don't think it's the
responsibility of filmmaker to teach the
audience morality or the difference
between right and wrong these comments
provoked a new wave of backlash with
some people dunking on him oh no no
that's that was from another part that
got cut well then just forget about what
I just said so there you have it I
really don't see what's all the hubbub
it's just like tax their taxi drivers a
perfect another example of an aunt
violent psycho can't take authority on
the wig like they said John wick what
tax cut taxes like trying to be taxi
driver so it really isn't taxi driver
was about an N cell he was obsessed
weird and sell psycho it's exactly the
same but we celebrate that movie as one
of the best ever made the problem is not
the movie the problem is this reality
right now with all the shooting right I
mean the movies but I just love that the
US military is issuing warnings it's
like what
I mean unless they know something no
they said they have no credible threats
but I guess there's just a bunch of in
sales on forums probably saying some
dumb [ __ ] and then everyone's got a trip
out what is wrong with these psychos I
don't know how is there a whole group of
these sick pathetic man they should just
[ __ ] each other just do that if you're
if you're such a great catch why don't
you just [ __ ] each other you know what I
mean
the in cells would look at each other
like I would never [ __ ] you you're a
disgusting dirtbag yeah exactly
I'd love to see it and self-loathing
anyways you know what I mean like it's
it's almost like the involuntary part is
wrong because it's like it isn't
involuntary it's totally voluntary like
you said it's like you just stop if you
just pull yourself out of this cycle
yeah self-hate you know yeah like you
said the Santa Barbara guy pulled up
pictures of him like he's not gonna stud
or anything but he's not a bad person
yeah it would have been had no problem
landing a girl so I mean he was fit no
it's like you almost feel bad for them
but they are just like so awful that you
can't I just come at me anything girls
get away harder with looks because guys
look at actually the looks well that's a
lot of girls one of the ironies of these
insults and that they're obsessed with
beautiful girls right right
because for girls don't look at anyone
pretty much it's not all about looks
look at my relationship with you thank
you yeah that's that if you guys guys
are always dating out of their league
that's ID girls are you very forgiving I
do think so and I think that if anything
guys are the ones who are more obsessed
with looks well that's I mean the
insults say it they go why are all these
beautiful women why are they not dating
me it's like I don't want to [ __ ] a fat
chick I'd rather kill everybody at my
school than [ __ ] fat chick
you know what I'm saying yes no I don't
know if this fousey boxing segment is
too violent to show he literally I
reminded me of The Simpsons when Homer
was a boxer got punched in the face like
it wasn't just awful like you never
raise his hands and it was just a total
[ __ ] show they were bad but at least at
least this other guy nice to could land
a punch
I mean Fosse was punching like this you
know he was swinging from the side like
he wasn't throwing up sir and he never
raised his hands the announcers were
getting worried they're like here I
could play the audio maybe I'll just
play the audio but you get you get I
love how they get so concerned i budget
event
punched in the face every second every
second you guys he just got punched in
the face 20 times
I mean I'm impressed by the way he's
able to stand up training for a while
but I was just surprised what's with
youtubers and fighting it they keep
getting more and more worried for fousey
because his face is just minced meat so
he broke his nose Instagram let me see
um he here let me see here's on
Instagram that aftermath I mean I've
never seen mater attempt at boxing I
swear to god he got I mean if anything
I'm impressed by how he can take a punch
but Homer Simpson comparison well I did
notify yourself let me find that let me
find that clip cuz it's so good oh
that's an instant I don't know about
claim yeah but you guys remember that
episode where he fought Mike Tyson he
was like this he was so he could take a
punch they would just punch him in the
head like a thousand times until they
were exhausted and the home were just
pushing him over so that's what first he
was doing except the guy didn't hair out
that's crazy
the announcer was like he's got to put
his hands up oh this isn't good
they got a call they got a call it foo
see put your hands on the bangers a lot
earlier honestly it's kind of
irresponsible reffing to let that keep
going hey it's for charity
yeah so here's a video he did with a
nose doctor I mean this this was pretty
good hey I'm dr. Jay Calvert and I'm
here to tell you what's going on with
Yusuf he has a the kid is pretty severe
so instructing his breathing and we're
gonna do a very simple procedure to try
to restore where his nose was before the
trauma oh my god and then in the future
we'll probably have to do a full-on
nasal reconstruction because he can't
make my nose smaller about today do the
same well probably it won't be exactly
the same but we're gonna try to get you
back so at least you can breathe ah
thanks slim that's the guy
Wow he probably broke his nose and like
one of the first rounds and then he just
he got punched in the face like I'm not
kidding like 300 times he was just I
mean it was unbelievable
it was hard to watch man he sounds like
the Elephant Man looks like him little
bit
they raised well the good news is that
they raised for charity Yemen we care
they raised 115 thousand pounds so
that's nice it's nice there's a
fundraiser for the war in Yemen yes
alright so I mean cause I mean yeah I
got I mean hey mm-hmm god bless right
yeah I don't know I don't know if they
got paid but I know that they raised a
bunch of money so nice good for you
[ __ ] yeah good for you damn you guys
should watch it it's on YouTube it was a
free event I just I don't want to show
it because it's like so brutal so
violent yeah
my guns dinged and it's hard to watch
man it's like 13 minutes of just fousey
getting punched in the face it's crazy
the nerd city made a video nerd city did
this whole thing nice Channel but you
guys should check out nerd city if you
don't so he's talking about a research
that this guy CeeLo did
and he plugged in a bunch of words he
published a report they did it jointly
so they published a report conducted
over the course of two months where they
tested YouTube's algorithm for keywords
to see what would trigger ad
monetization there was a third guy too
by the way
we shouldn't leave out icy nerd City
YouTube analyzed oh yes he'll oh good
their methodology was to upload two
second clips that had no D monetizable
audio or video with different keywords
if a video was yellowed they would try
the same keyword again this time
replacing the bad word with either happy
or friend for example a video might be
kids explained gay marriage that gets
turned yellow but then they replace the
word gay with happy and then the video
was approved on the second time so a lot
of this stuff they found out seems to
contradict their recent statements on
the subject of lgbtq+ stuff getting
yellowed and the video CeeLo says in the
case of lgbtq+ content bots can
interpret certain terms negatively if
they are regulating a high number of
homophobic or hateful content I think I
think nerd City raised a good point
because basically when the bot flacks
something yellow it gets thrown to a
human reviewer and then they either
overturned the boss decision or hold the
boss decision and they used those human
reviews to educate the bot now he may
raise a really good point he says human
bias is going to prejudice the bots
views and he says the people who are
working on doing these manual flagging
for YouTube there's 10,000 people they
recently hired and the company that they
work with has people cheap laborers all
throughout the world mostly in places
like you know India and other more
conservative-leaning cultures where for
example a gay gay culture is not yet
accepted I mean or or is just outright
outright sin
Minister and so he's thesis was good
that he says if you're giving these
decisions over to the people like this
their bias is gonna leak in mm because
these are not American people these are
these are low-wage global workforce and
I think that's a really interesting
point that I hadn't thought about that
YouTube chief product officer stated I
can tell you categorically that there is
no list of words or key words or terms
or anything like that is going into our
classifiers making an appropriate
decision on whether our videos are
monetized or not there's nothing in
terms of how we monetize algorithms
there's nothing in terms of how our
monetization algorithm works that should
be based on any kind of pre described or
predetermined list in his videos see
those states given our testing results
it's made clear that these comments are
not accurate I think they're they're
definitely lying by omission because
they're like yeah we didn't tell the bot
to D monetize the work okay
I just learned yeah that it should yeah
what's the difference I don't know if
there's a difference but Susan in an
interview with Alfie yeah a lot of
people talked about that interview where
she was directly asked if videos with
certain words would get auto flagged and
you know we we actually goofed on a
group of LGBTQ youtubers filed a class
action lawsuit against YouTube right
alleging that there was a discriminatory
do monetization of their of their
content and this video actually fuels a
lot of their gives them a lot of
credibility this research seems to
strengthen their case significantly I
have some examples of words that are
yellowed that they found in their
research Isis is the only word that
stands alone Rovers are in a yellow
murder is green murderer is yellow no
the just be clear the Isis one is like
an auto block oh you just go bye-bye
yeah that that one is like and that's
like they don't like other stuff D
monetization but if Isis is in there
it's like just blah
that's that's probably fair yeah yeah Oh
Isis used to post a bunch of videos on
you yeah obviously [ __ ] anything having
to do with that yeah let's keep them off
you too yeah
do you think that the ISIS guys
uploading we're like fans of like
keemstar they're like they watch a
little team getting on the news
upload a couple of just recruiting
videos you know I mean Isis definitely
watches keemstar
keep stars the preferred channel of ice
romance is yellow scottish is yellow but
Scott Linn and Scott are both green
there's a funny allegation rumors are
yellow but alleged is green pea is
yellow yes it is as is anything related
to urine but the word urine itself is
green undress is green undressing is
yellow anything with ass in it well
these ones are hobbies example ones that
are greed these are green a slick ass
licker ass [ __ ] ass monkey ass munch and
[ __ ] are all fine
that's why though yeah like most a stuff
is yellow but all this that you just
said oh this was interesting that all
the conservative youtubers have been
kind of thinking that they're being
censored there's been a whole thing
about it and apparently all those
political words are Green which
surprised me hmm like do you have any
specific examples Dan that you recalled
well it was more it was more so the lack
of examples I went through the entire
list of yellow words and a you know
conservative Republican Trump like just
anything having to do with like
right-wing politics basically which is
all green so that kind of counters their
you know persecution conflicts they got
going on now here's the ones that that
was the big scandal the LGBT terms
that get yelled automatically as gay
lesbians trans homosexual LGBT LGBTQIA
and so it was pretty interesting little
research here yeah there's a whole
spreadsheet but with a list of thousands
of words that they've tested it says
it's what do you think about it seems
like there's an issue with this I don't
know I mean it's like what did you guys
say that Jews get yellow but Jewish it
doesn't Jew gets yellow Jews use it
there's a weird thing I noticed a
pattern that with a lot of terms the
plural version of whatever it is is
yellow whereas the singular is not so
like it was the same thing for must
Muslim fine Muslims yellow Jew fine it
must be the way that hateful content
right it's just the context in which
it's used to be more like hateful video
would say like you know Muslims are
horrible right what I'm what I'm seeing
is that this bot is not intelligent
stupid it's simplistic there's no
intelligence at all I don't know but I
guess it's probably doing a lot of good
for them right I mean it must be yeah so
can't rely that it's too poor using yeah
yeah I mean there's just a lot of
billion [ __ ] videos to look at and so
they need to automate it in some way
yeah but these bots they don't have any
nuances yeah everything together
but when they talk about machine
learning and algorithms you expect more
intelligence than just this works bad
yellow alright but I like I made some
some videos when we were living in
Israel and any time I write Israel or
two or something like that it's yellow
Israel was yellow I mean God yellow okay
so and so
so is Palestine it's dying in
Palestinian yeah so I think again it's
because oh the conflicts there's a lot
of negative videos associated with those
terms and it just gets lumped in but let
you said it's like okay the whole
country is way too obtuse yeah but I
what I'm assuming happens is the bot
goes the frequency of times people use
the word Israel his contact person is
more controversial than it is not yeah
yeah which is probably true which is the
same with the work Jews versus thank you
right yeah I don't know what to say
though it seems very ham-handed that
what they're doing here yeah and that
extended beyond like the religious stuff
to vape still vaping know that the vape
name go way down a cut way down hey and
by the way can I just a quick aside
there were a lot of people super
triggered by what we were talking about
with the vaping thing they were why
because we weren't clear enough because
at the time there was still a lot of
ambiguity going on and a lot of
misreporting going on in the news the
nobody apparently nobody has died from
the nicotine babes
it's all THC THC black-market cartridges
that's what's [ __ ] people up and I
guess to some people we were not clear
about that enough and I guess Ian told
me he saw and read it on like the vaping
subreddits they were talking about me
specifically bro I used to be the nation
and now I'm the baby so did you get
skewered in the comment stand yeah I
mean people I'd have to go back and
watch it I thought I was indicating that
it seemed like it was the THC stuff but
again it was all still like breaking
news at the yeah and we've learned a lot
more just in the past week even so I
want to some of the I want some of the
outrageous comments from that yeah so
are you banned from the vape community
I guess I'm person non grata in the
vapor community you got to give up faith
and go on a vaporous is that I'm I'm
happy to to cut down and quit anyways it
I I was just taking it as like along
this is a good excuse
don't be shocked at taking a huge
[ __ ] rip of of like the amount of
vapor you inhale is insane there's don't
be surprised it's not good for you
yeah I mean smoking is one thing of
course it's awful like definitely worse
than bassist say I mean marijuana
smokers have the same fallacy they
refused to believe that smoking is bad
I'm like you are inhaling smoke into
your lungs it's bad yeah well I don't
weed smoker and I switched to the to the
vape cartridges for that reason I'm sure
it's better than now inhaling smoke but
I don't know I mean nobody I mean you
don't you're not gonna drop dead from
hitting a joint right exactly
no I've gone back to the normal stuff
now I can't believe people are dropping
dead their clones are collapsing it's
insane it's crazy and we had a fan email
us about it I guess I think we actually
talked about it vitamin E or something
there they're putting my yeah that's the
other dilute that was the other thing is
that I didn't mention the vitamin E
which actually did know about but I I
had just that day read about the cyanide
thing and so I brought that up and
people excused you for that you know
sorry or not we're not a hundred percent
accurate on our hard-hitting reporting
on the vape stuff hmm getting a little
taste a little dose of what I deal with
is falling apart are you gonna issue an
apology [ __ ] no struggle
are you sure cuz I mean come on are you
gonna live like this you know welcome or
welcome what they're doing is they're
cutting the vape juice or that yeah the
vape juice with vitamin E okay to make
this you know cut costs yeah and the
vitamin E actually like is toxic and it
makes your lungs collapse right so these
idiots are saving a couple bucks and
they're people are just the guy who
emailed us and this is just some random
guy who emailed us but this was the guy
that's that claims that his lung
collapsed a couple months ago wow that
sucks yeah and he and he says that they
could turn one THC cartridges into three
so by doing this I mean there
the profits essentially so my money
exactly it's [ __ ] up but yeah I mean
it's a profit motive well that's where
they cut and it's like dude yeah I'm
gonna cut cocaine with fentanyl but that
doesn't that doesn't make sense to me
because I don't see that make saving
them money
I guess they get higher and they think
it's good you put a little fentanyl in
it retinol fentanyl
well fentanyl is cheaper also I don't
think they cut cocaine or they were
cutting like xanax with it like that's a
yeah opioids cuz fentanyl is like
nobody's antics not an opioid okay
well I'm not sure that's a little Sam
died he oh you're right Sam died that
way because he was taking the beep died
that way because he had xanax that was
cut with fentanyl I'm like why would
they put fentanyl in xanax it doesn't
make sense yeah well I think they're
just trying to get you high
so you still enjoy it but then he takes
a bunch of Xan expecting to fall asleep
and he doesn't wake up cuz he took of
shitload of fentanyl which is like the
strongest opioid ever made yeah anyway
but hey don't do drugs kids yeah I mean
in short because people are crazy who
knew the drug dealers were immoral
people that's why I think all drugs
should be legal exactly I was about to
say this I think the government should
sell drugs if you're and safe
they should have [ __ ] drug abuse is a
drug abuse is age is it's a treatable
disease I mean as long as alcohol is
legal yeah what's the difference you can
abuse alcohol just crazy as anything
yeah same with weed if I'm being honest
wheat is insane if you smoke too much
weed boy I can't that'll [ __ ] your month
up seriously
I I don't totally disagree with what
you're saying but I would I think that
alcohol is way worse than we first
thought
yeah alcohol is not well to me not to me
weird is worse oh yeah
they're both very strong real drugs I
mean I've been so [ __ ] up on WiiWare
I'm like this is insane yeah I've never
been this high on anything I'm in outer
space in that way alcohol I just pass
out
well okay you pass out you don't wake up
I was afraid you died the last time you
get drunk you look in New York I carried
it up three flights of stairs the last
time we got drunk hammered drunk yeah
Jesus anyway I think we covered
everything guess so
I have a couple of gaffes here we're
over the two-hour mark here let me just
wrap it up since we're going the
distance here I've got advice for salt
Bay
I've got a new Turkish cooking segments
so I'll bait this guy's such a clown
first of all it has to slice meat down
the middle like that dude you know what
I'm saying like what are you doing well
shall we just and then I don't think
you're supposed to fling pieces of raw
meat out over your kitchen haphazardly
like that like just like dude what are
you doing something I hit the roof wrong
eat bro you got to keep your kitchen
clean look at it throwing raw meat
around a five-year-old he didn't season
it he didn't do anything he literally
put it in the oven
what am I supposed I'd love to see
Gordon Ramsay analyze what's going on
here dude what did you do you didn't do
anything you didn't do anything he
literally didn't do it that's my cookie
he didn't seize it he didn't do anything
like dude watch how he throws at me
listen it hits the roof bro listen this
one
it's stuck on the roof that cut there
yeah okay I'm sure that tastes great
there's no oil or seasoning or anything
on it Wow I can't wait to eat that he
slammed the oven door okay dude where
are you getting season that looks raw by
the way they look I don't like that's so
stupid it's so done and then here's a
guy who does know how to cook Oh
actually no look what tell me what sorry
I thought it was our Turkish smiling boy
but it's actually a different Turkish
one this looks to me like raw chicken
and it looks so hard and putrid can
anybody tell me what we're dealing with
here look at this it looks like raw
chicken mush dude what is it well shall
we know if that's me but what is it I
like how he cuts into it it looks like
raw chicken it does kind of look like
raw chicken but that's it there's
nothing in the comments well it's all
Turkish I just see one guy said damn all
the food on stage looks hella good well
we got Turkish fans they always reach
out when we talk about these chefs so if
you know what this dish is good I like
how it says I cut into it it's just mush
it looks like a raw chicken yeah no
that's a weird one
I love Turkish cuisine we're gonna have
to go to Turkey food tequila mm-hmm
can we go to Turkey as you as Israelis
yeah it depends on the times sometimes I
don't want to go to a place where it
depends on the time when maybe it's the
time and then all the sudden while
you're there is not the time I only go
to places where it's at the time all the
time that's our life Ethan you gotta
take some risk no I'm not going I'm not
going to anywhere now I've been to
Turkey yeah but that was before it was
not the time yeah that was before air go
down or whatever
I don't know what's the time right now
it's a bad time it's not a good time and
check the memos it's not a good time for
Israelis an Israeli so we're American I
just looked it up yeah well actually you
would have
oh it says well yeah but I mean come on
I mean I don't need to bring my Israeli
recording for this it says no visas are
required for Israelis to visit Turkey
yeah it looks like it's alright I mean
kidnapped if something if there's a if
it's a bad climate I don't want a
kidnapped illa it's not worth the
[ __ ] kebabs but we're not going to
speak Hebrew you don't dog Kiba
obviously I don't talk to you anywhere
really I think the question is can Jews
go to Turkey yeah well Israelis can
everyone there I'm very modern country
you're Turkish I don't have Turkey well
half Libyan it's in the shame you can't
even go to your home country without
being afraid of being kidnapped no I can
it's not that we can go to Turkey yeah
I've been there and well you can cry no
but you what they're like like 15 years
ago
yeah but that was before the time that
was bad times I don't think so I just
that would be a great food vlog just
eating all the crazy food in Turkey
going to the smile guy's place
salt-based from Turkey it's all
happening in Turkey it's a culinary
Renaissance raw chicken scoops I'll do
it all
oh yeah okay well that's the show hope
you had fun hope you have a great
weekend I'm sick so I'm gonna go lay
down take it easy
Tuesday we're having Bobby and kalila
back yeah they were sick they had to
council we were sick so we cancelled
first coming out Tuesday I'm happy to
say and I'm working on some bookings I'm
very excited about two for example
Trisha well we got Trisha Paytas on the
books write down who that is true we
fire her they'll be a and I'm also
working on getting Dog the Bounty
Hunter's
- Aloha yeah that'll be cool that dog in
here yeah I would like to get some hair
tips
I know thank you you should might go to
your hair dogs no we should hire an
extra to like come in here like a
criminal and have him like apprehend him
citizen's arrest
who else I'm sure I get angry yang back
to after the next debate mmm in November
you guys have suggestions though let me
know because I feel like we can we have
a good rapport we can get a lot of
people I just don't know who to to reach
out to sometimes yeah
for example two of my favorite guests
we've had is Jordan Peterson Andrew
getting those both suggested to me by my
brother but my brother on your brother
yeah and I just tweeted at them and they
were both down which was so cool so
let's keep it going
who would you like to see on the podcast
podcast a h3 brush is a comet of snow
you got the music going no well I've
been holding off I always start it and
then you go off on a tangent and then we
run out of just play the damn you live
[Music]
I just saw this morning that I just I
just saw this morning that Roseann was
just on joe rogan again so we may have
some new sound bites for you soon okay
that's okay I don't know how well ever
caught the ear but was it a good play it
is alright everybody thanks for watching
we will see you next Tuesday with the
Bobbili take care have a great weekend
everyone